yeah oh yeah like I was like is this
about my channel I can't remember
hi guys this is so exciting look who's
here maimry hart and joseline you know
trying to figure out her noise for a
while
joseline is the queen of DIY and has a
book coming out all about it this
November right no ever there you got my
damn it once you got that belly ache
from all that candy you just stay and
you want to change your life up because
that many mini-snickers is just wrong by
that book oh you're talking about
Halloween yeah personally watch joseline
DIY firsthand and it's very impressive
I'm awful at DIY Mabry's really good
idea works cute you helping ice exhaust
you for the compliment
I really wanted joseline to come and
teach us something that's from her book
and so what are we doing today we are
gonna make that called tin you can do it
candles huh tin you can do it it's the
easiest as someone who has a candle
addiction movie - girl I got a new
pumpkin spice not like one yesterday
I burned half of it down it's a three
wick there was no need for that
but there is that's why I started making
your candles I need a serious
the most serious conversation between
two basics how do we do this okay so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
flip to this project in my book and redo
to the instructions you're gonna read
the instructions and wait to try and
follow along first I'm going to tell you
the supplies you need DIY damnit a
practical guide to Krispies crafting
materials 10
thank you spray paint optional Sharpie
paint markers yes I'm going with the hot
glue sticks so a wax wick we're not
going to do work
where'd you get these from a candle
superstore in North Hollywood that I go
to and they don't have a candle
super-short could they buy them on
Amazon yet skewer or stick back chips oh
they're not coconut no as a rough
martini
I know if you buy soy wax you need soy
wicks but I also heard that soy wax
burns so much slower than than other way
and more even yeah so these candles are
going to last for a few days scent and
color is optional and scissors reviews
sense to use like a central wheel you
can use essential oils they also sell
candle scents like they might have all
pack that has like cinnamon apple and
like pumpkin breeze and stuff like that
yes sort of a venti of attitude you have
a lot of basic [ __ ] right here this is
a human goop news look alright let's get
rich yes
clean your tin can which I've already
done for you I'm Liv tell shorty gold
lady evolve amiibo I want don't reveal
it you can also spray paint it with a
base color if you desire oh my god I did
desire Wow and I let it dry
strike I remember when you had beans in
you not know I was gonna grab your make
your beans action yeah that could be
real high number two you're gonna paint
a design onto the can with your paint
markers I love paint markers on my
website there's gonna be like a bunch of
templates with my ideas they're fun
because they're also a musical
instrument man
that made up genre that jostle animation
I already regret everything started to
do the white and then the marketing work
so I picked up a red and now it just
looks like a clown from the 80s there
any kind of marker that you can't like
heat up like once this is lit you know
to me oh that's a good question to
Google next you're going to happen it a
wick this buddy onto the bottom of the
camp then you buy wicks it will tell you
the diameter it burns so this one is two
to three inches which is perfect for
these cans do I need to cut this not yet
because you had a floor wax it poom
let's see if this book instructions are
correct this is a good proofreading it
is you did for free after never know you
should always you should always check
after a different okay you're gonna take
your skewer and you're going to wrap the
top of the wick around the skewer like
this yep and then you're going to place
it on the top of the can oh so when you
pour the wax the wick stays in place
which is oh that's so smart look at that
look at that look at that okay now I'm
gonna get the wax the wax and we're
going to pour the wax in this stuff is
what gets melted and out the wax chips
according to the package directions
adding scent and color if that's your
jam okay we changed your mind we decided
to add a scent and we added pumpkin
soufflé pumpkin soufflé while losing our
goddamn mind you know thanks complex
it's really good yeah it's so good I dip
my feet in there and let it harden
several times to where they're my own
version of Uggs like rylindia basic
[ __ ] with pumpkin scented stuff and
Uggs pumpkins into dogs yes number six
you're going to pour the wax of the can
and
Harden's just like Colonial Williamsburg
it is just like it oh my god you guys
I'm so sorry bit so now I'm going to let
the wax harden and then you're going to
trim the top of your wick after it's
hard
uh-huh to a quarter-inch and then you
burn that [ __ ] and that's it yeah how
does it take for it to cool wait a
couple hours okay
here's our last time here's what I say
we'll let them cool and then right now
cut to a pic of the finish handles whoa
look at you tin you can do it
tin you can do it candles when I make it
it's the opposite of a Yankee Candle
yes how much of the wax do we actually
use like I had no idea you buy it in
bulk how much is it involved like what
it was $10 for that giant carpet and we
still have a huge amount left and we
made three candles with it it's usually
$10 for a candle at Bath & Body that's
it I give this candle a 10
well thank you joseline 42 alcohol to
make these candles this is so easy make
sure if you want to make things like
this or 34 other craft projects you get
a copy of DIY damnit
yeah DIY Danna calm or at any of your
local retailers I want to end it also
check out Mary
she sells herself thanks for watching
thank you guys for being here telling me
I don't know this book can be a gift but
you can also use it to make gifts it is
a gift that keeps on giving